europe soir week end jeanne baron dans
quelques jours des milliers d'écoliers
vont retrouver le banc de l'école
parfois avec la gorge nouée et la peur
au ventre parce qu'après deux années de
covin c'est pas fini il a garé en
ukraine est venu à nous a ajouté pardon
une épée de damoclès supplémentaire au
dessus de la tête des étudiants
notamment l'inflation est telle que
certains savent déjà qu'ils vont vivre
une année économique et psychologique
extrêmement difficile bonsoir sarrail
l'aeri bonsoir merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté mon invitation ce soir pour
europe 1 vous êtes secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre des armées et du
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse vous êtes également chargé
de la jeunesse et du service national
universel voilà beaucoup de travail pour
vous sa riley y en a un il y en a et en
même temps c'est absolument l'essence et
de la jeunesse c'est ce qui n'a de
l'énergie c'est pour ça qu'on bâtit
c'est pour ça qu'on a les familles et
parce que ça parce que ça tient à coeur
à tout le monde et bien c'est la
priorité du gouvernement pap ndiaye est
justement le ministre de l'éducation
promet des conditions de rentrée en val
cité convenable à défaut d'optimal est
ce qu'aujourd'hui sarra el aissi vous
pouvez nous garantir qu'il y aura un
enseignant devant chaque classe à la
rentrée un enseignant pas un adulte vous
savez l'éducation nationale une rentrée
c'est plus de 12 millions 12 millions de
jeunes d'enfants qui rentrent qui rentre
à l'école et c'est normal qu'on ait des
inquiétudes c'est normal quand on donne
ce qu'on a de plus cher de plus précieux
à la rentrée d'une porte de ces pays où
vous emmène son enfant que la première
collège on est inquiet est ce que j'ai
envie de vous dire aujourd'hui c'est que
c'est plus de 800 mille enseignants qui
accompagne cette rentrée alors oui c'est
pas simple parce que aujourd'hui le
métier d'enseignant ils appellent à de
nouvelles vocations parce qu'il ya une
crise en profondeur et on peut se le
dire et c'est pour ça que on a des
réponses un peu en deux temps d'abord
l'urgence l'urgence c'est d'avoir oui
des hommes et des femmes qui sont qu'ils
voient est devant nos enfants qui vont
leur transmettre des savoirs qui vont
les accompagner et aussi répondre à
cette crise des vocations avec des
rémunérations nouvelle avec aussi un
projet nouveau plus de sens mais ce qui
est certain c'est que la rentrée
scolaire c'est un moment qu'un rituel
républicain dans notre pays et nous
accompagnerons avec toute notre énergie
pour qu'elle soit la plus réussie
possible sans votre énergie sarah l'air
et on la sent notamment ici en direct de
ce studio pour ceux qui nous écoutent
mais ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'on peut pas en tire un enseignant
devant chaque classe oui il y aura des
contractuels ce que vous avez dit on ne
peut pas faire autrement il faut pallier
à la crise que l'on vit vous savez un
contractuel c'est quoi en réalité parce
qu'on avait l'impression qu'on
stigmatise un petit peu ces hommes et
ces femmes c'est des hommes et des
femmes qui sont diplômés parfois
d'autres matières c'est vrai qu'ils ont
qui font le choix de rentrer dans ce
qu'il a de plus précieux c'est à dire
l'école d'être formé de continuer à se
former en formation continue
d'appartenir à des équipes pédagogiques
ne sont pas tout seuls ils sont
accompagnés par des équipes des
rectorats par leurs collègues mais
surtout il est une formation continue et
c'est des hommes et des femmes qui sou
pour en grande partie d'entre eux
l'année dernière était déjà au sein de
nos établissements et puis on va
relativiser un petit peu sur l'école
élémentaire c'est moins de 1 % sur
l'école sur le collège donc le
secondaire on est à 8% on parle de plus
de 860 5000 enseignants dans notre pays
et moi je salue ces contractuels qui
viennent et bien accompagner cette
transmission de nos enfants et je sais
que leur engagement et sans relâche et
vous comprendrez aussi de l'autre côté
l'école qui souffre depuis des années
qui n'est pas valorisé pour nous bien
revalorisé encore faut-il et de
valoriser pourquoi est ce qu'on ne prend
pas le problème à la racine l'éducation
nationale qui s'effondre depuis des
années aller chercher des contractuels
faire des jobs dating pourquoi pas à
condition de savoir ce que l'on veut
pour l'école quelle est sa vocation mais
d'un autre côté pour qu'on ne prend pas
le mal à la racine eh bien c'est
exactement la réponse qu'a rapporté hier
le président de la république à la
sorbonne et c'est un moment historique
parce que ça a été la première fois
qu'un président de la république parle à
l'ensemble des recteurs avec le ministre
de l'éducation nationale pap ndiaye
c'est quoi le projet ni projet essentiel
c'est évidemment répondre à ce malaise à
ce désarroi qui existe sinon il y aurait
pas aussi peu de volontaires répondre
comment revaloriser oui les salaires
parce qu'un métier qui rémunère pas
suffisamment bien ne crée pas
d'attractivité mais redonner le sens
d'être enseignant remettre aussi le
respect l'autorité au sein de nos
établissements plus de liberté
pédagogique et c'est pour ça que hier le
président de la république annoncé quoi
il a annoncé une revalorisation plus un
ancien niant qu'ils aura un salaire en
dessous de 2000 euros nets une
revalorisation de 10% de mille euros
c'est pas que je vais la prendre quand
on est enseignant depuis 30 ans est ce
qu'on peut appeler ça une valorisation
revalorisation des salaires
les 2000 euros ils sont pour le nouveau
en scène et les ans les anciens il ya
une revalorisation qui est en cours et
qui sera faite de plus de 10% pour tout
l'ensemble des anciens et mais il a
proposé c'est ce qu'ils disent mais
quand mais quand il y en a qui sont à
1700 euros nets et 30 ans mais si c'est
en cours et le débat budgétaire mais
bien sûr je les comprends que les
intellos n'est évidemment et ce débat
idée il va être en cours durant cet
automne et vous savez moi je vais aller
même plus loin puisque le président
république l'a rappelé hier il dit
évidemment il est parti inconditionnels
plus de 10% pour nos enseignants parce
que oui il faut mieux les payer il faut
mieux les accompagner mais tous ceux qui
liront un peu plus loin et qui feront le
choix vous savez on a des profs qui nous
emmène en classe de neige qui a acquis
100 qui qui s'engagent dans la ville
la vie l'encadrement de l'école et bien
eux ils iront jusqu'à 20 % parce qu'il
ya impact supplémentaire qui sera qu'on
pourra nouer avec l'école c'est ça le
renouveau de l'école avec aussi
philosophiquement peut-être deux points
un peu importants le premier l'essentiel
de l'école c'est quoi transmettre des
savoirs plus de mad plus d'anglais aller
chercher cette excellence et de l'autre
côté est bien plus de confiance dans nos
enfants pour leur permettre de grandir
et surtout savait donner cette énergie
alors oui on ira chercher l'excellence
de l'enseignement professionnel et
technologique on ira chercher
l'excellence de nos territoires et les
masques mais voilà les mots m au ts les
mots sont beaux mais les mots m11x au
grand et à la glisse est ce qu'on va
finalement mettre des actions sur des
mots m étais est vraiment est-ce qu'on
est ce qu'on agit en profondeur est
factuellement on a une augmentation
historique du budget ça c'est en termes
de moyens c'est pour moi l'élément de
preuve que oui l'investissement ce n'est
pas que des mots m au ts mais ce n'est
pas une rentrée des déclarations c'est
une rentrée des actes une rentrée des
actes si oui à les accompagner des
contractuels augmenter le salaire de nos
enseignants et donner les moyens aux
chefs d'état faisant bien sûr parce que
ces précieux la rentrée scolaire l'école
et l'inflation la hausse des prix des
budgets de fournitures scolaires hausse
des budgets également des cantines les
cantines où on va réduire les portions
peut-être devoir choisir entre le
fromage et le dessert est ce que le
gouvernement a raté le coche c'est très
dur et des mères qui disent on ne pourra
pas joindre les deux bouts
volistes inflation elle touche de plein
fouet notre pays et on est un des pays
en europe qui s'en sort le mieux parce
que quand le pouvoir d'achat de notre
pays des français touchés on est au
rendez vous le pouvoir d'achat ça a été
une loi qui a été porté avec je pense
avec une d'unité nationale au sein de
l'assemblée nationale alors même que
nous avons une majorité relative est
allé à la hauteur eh bien elle répond
elle répond peut-être que elle répondra
encore avec plus de 2 de
personnalisation je donne un exemple
très concret on bloque les prix
évidemment de l'électricité on sait que
c'est trop lourd sur les budgets on à la
question aujourd'hui des fonds sociaux
dans les écoles pour répondre aux
besoins des familles c'est maman qui
disent moi ça sera très dur pour moi et
bien ce matin le ministre éducation
nationale pap ndiaye il a annoncé une
augmentation de plus de 50% des fonds
sociaux ça veut dire moi maman peut être
monoparentale qui ne peut pas faire plus
ce que je m'en sors plus eh bien je
pourrais avoir une aide supplémentaire
et de l'autre côté parce que ça a été le
débat parlementaire il y aura un
accompagnement d'un certain nombre de
collectivités pour aller chercher une
tarification plus sociale mais jusqu'à
quand mes héros différent de l'autre
côté on est vraiment dans la politique
sahara est là et ridules et en même
temps olivier ferrand explique juste
après que le bouclier est tarifaire ne
pourra pas durer éternellement et pas
durer éternellement ça veut dire qu'il
se passe quoi dans quelques mois il se
passe quoi envier espace espace d'abord
déjà la rentrée une allocation de
rentrée scolaire qui a augmenté qui a
augmenté de 4% il se passe que pour un
certain nombre est bien de fournitures
l'accompagnement est réel aujourd'hui
une rentrée vous savez pour un jeune en
sixième ce à peu près de 200 euros
l'allocation rentrée scolaire c'est en
moyenne en fonction de la composition
familiale 400 euros pour permettre à ses
enfants d'aller grandir sa vie l'école
c'est le seul endroit où il ya cette
égalité est à dire que on donne les
moyens à chaque jeune s'ils s'engagent
s'ils apprennent et bien de s'en sortir
allez pour shay soyons encore sarah
élève tout les revalorisations dont
celle des bourses ou des appels sont en
dessous de l'inflation toutes ces
revalorisations de cette fameuse loi le
paquet pouvoir d'achat comment est-ce
qu'on aide les étudiants vous venez dire
en france on a de la chance l'école
c'est presque gratuit et ingersheim
avant cette école à deux vitesses
seulement la réalité du terrain fait que
certains élèves ne peuvent pas
poursuivre leurs études parce qu'ils
n'ont pas assez d'argent que ce sont les
étudiants les plus riches soutenu
généralement par des familles qui vont
continuer est-ce qu'on n'est pas encore
la danse est dans cette époque du
serpent qui se mord la queue on répète à
nouveau non moi je moi je vous savez moi
je vis dans la réalité ils trouvent que
moi j'ai été boursière j'ai pu profiter
de cette solidarité deux pays pour
permettre à lanester elle est globale si
jamais ils permettent vous savez il n'ya
pas si longtemps que ça puisque j'ai 33
ans il est à peine quelques années mais
c'est plus amassé suffisamment pour
parler d'aujourd'hui et demain et démons
séquence aujourd'hui l'inflation
qu'est-ce qu'on répond aux étudiants
d'abord on gèle les frais d'inscription
on gèle les loyers des logements crous
on rénove les logements crous pour qu'il
n'ait pas de dépense énergétique trop
lourd trop forte on permet quoi leur
pain en euros à tous les étudiants
boursiers et est précaire et très calmes
et bien sûr à tous ceux qui en ont
besoin en réalité est donc ce n'est pas
simplement la revalorisation des bourses
de tous les échelons de bursa 4% c'est
aussi une aide supplémentaire pour tous
les étudiants qui sont parents parce que
moi je n'oublie pas les particularités
les diversité des situations quand tu es
tu dans ya des étudiants qui travaillent
et gestion qui sont parents et qui sont
en charge
une famille et des étudiants qui peuvent
avoir l'aide de leurs parents y en a qui
ne peuvent pas et c'est pour ça que ces
aides en particulier et bien le vent
touché plus de 1,5 million d'étudiants
dans notre pays aujourd'hui c'est
évidemment à voir cette aide de
solidarité l'accompagné avec les crous
et un étudiant qui en galère il faut pas
qu'ils pour qu'ils hésitent à pousser la
porte du crous parce qu il ya un
ascenseur peuple et je vais pas vous
l'apprendre les frais de scolarité les
geôles est d'accord mais n'ont pas
augmenté depuis cinq ans ont donc en
réalité le jeudi les îles et vous voyez
ils sont gelés mais les bourses est
brillante ils sont gelés et un mailing
on sait pas vous mais c'est ça la
question est ce que vous faites à ces
envois jordan fondamentalement quand je
regarde autour de nous quand je me dis
que nous notre université elle a permis
sur les cinq dernières années eh bien
deux je les ai effectivement le coup
d'aile et garantir une éducation
quasiment gratuite on n'est pas très
loin on est autour de 380 euros une
inscription universités que quand on
regarde du côté des états unis ou
d'autres pays eh bien le ticket d'entrée
c'est l'endettement pour un étudiant
pour qu'elle puisse étudier moi ce que
je vois c'est une jeunesse qui où il ya
des difficultés pour une partie d'entre
elles vie l'inflation dont la compagne
avec les repas un euro on enlevait la
sécurité le coup la sécurité sociale
pour les étudiants c'était 200 euros par
mo par an mais une école à deux vitesses
a réuni le privé qui ont osé au public
on il faut pas mentir aux français qu
est ce que vous pensez c'est tellement
plus facile d'avoir l'argent de faire
des études privées plutôt que des études
publiques et de galères et abord que ya
pas de professeurs ils sont pas
valorisées et on n'a pas d'argument
aller travailler moi moi je en fait je
ne souhaite pas porter ce message d'une
école à deux vitesses pour deux raisons
parce que l'école elle est républicaine
l'école elle donne sa chance à chaque
jeune chaque enfant est bien qu'il
s'investit dans son ex est ce que vous
dis aux jeunes français qui nous est en
sueur et je leur dis vous savez quoi
engagez vous engagez vous dans vos
écoles soyez délégué délégués de classe
rejoignez les conseils d'éducation fait
des engagements service civique
prenaient à bras le corps votre tout ce
qu'offre notre pays comme engagement
parce que ça émancipe par contre nous
posons jamais nous posons jamais parce
qu'on a quelque chose de très précieux
dans le pays c'est la liberté la liberté
de choisir alors est ce qu'il ya des
vies qui sont différentes quant à des
parents riches au moins ou moins riches
les glands bien sûr que bien sûr que
c'est pour ça que l'égalité des chances
c'est allait permettre non pas la même
ligne de départ parce que c'est pas vrai
par contre aller réussir la ligne
d'arrivée ça c'est notre job ça c'est
notre mission pas évident pour ceux qui
nous écoutent la dernière sarah elle est
beaucoup d'étudiants sont convaincus que
la jeunesse n'est toujours pas la
priorité du gouvernement de macron
pourquoi d'après vous que leur répondez
vous vous avez moins d'une minute en
moins d'une minute moi j'en veux dire un
jeune une solution 3 millions de jeunes
700000 apprentis aujourd'hui la jeunesse
au coeur de chacune des priorités de mai
de mes collègues il se trouve que en
quelques jours j'ai vu le ministre du
budget la ministre en charge de la
citoyenneté évidemment je travaille au
quotidien que le ministre des armées
ennemies de l'éducation nationale le
ministre de l'économie parce que dans le
fond pour répondre aux grands enjeux et
aux grands besoins de notre jeunesse
c'est quoi la promesse le rêve français
ces aides toi la république t'aidera
engage-toi prend pleinement ta place tu
n'as pas saisit ton destin n'attend pas
qu'on fasse à ta place c'est pas ça la
france par contre la france elle
reconnaît l'effort elle reconnaît le
mérite et elle sera là elle est juste et
elle sera là merci beaucoup salle ar à
saint raphaël à erie secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre des armées du
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse vous êtes chargé de la
jeunesse et du service national
universel notamment d'entre eux